that's what the kids want to see cut
everyone here loves behind the scenes
looks but for this one we're taking you
into the very strange world of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
this highly detailed and trippy feature
took care of everything from costumes to
practical effects who's ready to jump
realities with us
number one you need quite the
imagination for an mcu film and with
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness one should expect the cgi to be
strong traveling the multiverse can come
with lots of monsters and trippy worlds
plus a little extra of course i think
the whole thing was challenging because
there's so many elements that go from
shot to shot this little extra we
referred to is that wild sequence when
strange and america fall through dozens
of realities at once easy peasy for the
vfx team right not really some of you
may not understand this but just those
couple of seconds in the painted reality
probably utilized tons of computer power
we're expecting the oscars to open up a
category just for this computer the best
render of the year award
number two talk about blockbuster the
biggest day for production was the
filming of the battle of comitage
filmmakers coordinated the sequence
using three separate sound stages each
moment in the scene had to be precisely
coordinated over the series of weeks it
took to film it did an explosion happen
on set yesterday you better make sure
you show the damage at the location for
today the amount of extras and stunt
performers they used just added more
responsibilities to the mix production
coordinators not only had to watch out
for their safety but make sure each
person sold the timely moments the
impressively immersive camera work was
carefully planned out in advance to make
the audience feel as if they were wanda
hooking up a camera to a one chance
swinging it in a strafe run throughout
the stage
number three these practical effects
were a little too real for a superhero
movie whether it was because sam raimi
was directing or not most of the effects
used in this film were tangible on set
in referring to that explosive scene we
were just talking about they used a
whole new set of explosives to make it
safe and more realistic using high
pressure nitrogen the stump people were
able to literally stand on top of the
explosion without any worry of burns or
shock these scarlet witch's powers were
mainly done on set strapping led lights
to elizabeth olsen's hands then
polishing it up in the editing room
number four put in all the work to make
it as real as possible the dozens of
sets used for this sequel were not just
cookie cutter sets from other projects
it took set designers literally months
to put together each one focusing on the
finest of details the one that sounds
the most painstaking was the apple
orchard as wanda and strange stroll
through this beautiful farm we see
thousands of budding apple flowers
looked so real right but guess what they
were all fake and no they did not go the
easy route with cgi on this one hundreds
of production staff littered the barren
set tying on synthetic flowers to each
branch these are fabricated blossoms
that have been tied on to these trees by
hand each set was built as tangible as
possible not only to make the looks
stronger but the actor's performances as
well we mean who wouldn't want to step
foot in the actual comitage
number 5. wanda has undergone heavy
costume transformations over the course
of her character's journey the biggest
being her becoming the scarlet witch as
we know that she falls to the dark hold
her outfit had to feel its sinister
effects costume designers added
splotches of darkness to the top of the
costume making it seem as if she's being
consumed by darkness not just the main
part of her costume was affected but
also her crown and cape you get this
sort of multiversal mold and
contamination growing over your body
once a bright crown became a symbol of
evil number six did disney really just
go there you can't really have a sam
raimi movie without some zombies so this
one's understandable the writers really
wanted a zombie strange and while disney
was reluctant at first they were able to
squeeze him in this meant a whole new
challenge for benedict cumberbatch
creating the struggle physicality of a
walking corpse is no easy feat makeup
artists piled on those prosthetics
making the cgi work very minimal for vfx
artists to put it simply if the mcu can
push things this far we can't imagine
where they'll be taking strange next
number 7 every sam raimi stand knows
that he's got a very specific direction
style and this evil dead director made
sure to make doctor strange as full of
madness as it gets there were so many
rainy horror aspects to this from the
creeping camera movements possessions
and of course mirrors but the real
rainism comes from the appearance of his
high school car the 73 delta 88. this
classic car has been featured in the
background of all his films but someone
really wants to destroy it for no
apparent reason i have to say i hate it
but i love it number eight the jackets
gotta match the actors style and for
gomez it did a lot more than that
costume designers had created hundreds
of different versions for america's
jacket honing in on the tiniest of
details they made sure to use a lot of
this cultural inspiration to really
bring the character to life mexican sort
of folkloric art and day of the dead
references if you look closely you can
even see lines of poetry added to the
combat style piece but the most
important part the star this star was
made to create the perfect focus point
of the personality of this character
literally being that she opens star
portals to enter universes but
metaphorically being that she is the
bright savior of this universe
number nine a little costume recycling
never hurt anyone except for sinister
strange who really just wore it down
utilizing the same outfit from end game
designers added a lot of dark magic
effects to this alternate strange and
all that was needed at this point was
the talented cumberbatch's acting he
really wanted to push toward the darker
edge of this character without making
him just another cheesy villain
number 10. well who knew that young
people loved tik tok we weren't mad
about that especially when sochil gomez
gets benedict wong to join in on a few
dances these two were quite the content
duo behind the scenes busting moves with
wong's signature bluetooth speaker
although it looks like benedict will
have to stretch a little more for
tick-tock she tried to teach me some
moves but uh
i think i pulled the muscle number 11 it
looks like marvel was caught red-handed
on this one we really thought
cumberbatch was randomly waving his
hands around but our feeble minds were
surprised to learn that it's not that
simple and choreographer jay funk was
brought on to give the magic behind the
hand movements each spell is directly
related to each specific hand movement
definitely gotta hand it to jay on this
one nice work
number 12 this entry is brought to you
by tuning forks the only way to get
elizabeth olsen to enjoy flying around
the set she's no stranger to harnesses
and unlike many other mcu actors she
actually enjoys being up there and
thrashing around i really do enjoy it a
lot those so-called big metal tuning
forks gave her a comfy huggy feeling
even though to us that just looks like a
whole lot of dizzy
number 13. did you catch that strange
comic book reference we'll talk about
the illuminati a little later but that
suit he's wearing in that scene is
actually inspired by the suit from the
comic in which strange was a part of the
secret society sam loved this idea
taking good care of comic nostalgia but
not forcing it on the audience there's
not much to be said about strange's
signature outfit but maybe he might
consider getting it washed from time to
time
number 14 originating a comic book
superhero character is terrifying to us
enough but can you imagine being one of
the youngest actors in all the mcu it's
crazy it's
it's really like oh my goodness well
that was social gomez the one that's a
lot more brave than us she had never
tackled the film of this caliber but it
seemed like she had the support she
needed to get through it and being
literally thrown into these kinds of
stunts makes us appreciate our america a
lot more
number 15 and away he goes yes you're
seeing that right they actually got this
die-hard theater actor flying through
the air
so much happened so quickly
marvel just really likes the main cast
on arnis's and for cumberbatch he seems
to really enjoy that part stunt
coordinators really harnessed him up
dozens of feet in the air flying him
through sound stages and sets alike the
goal was to get as much of benedict's
real face as possible without having the
need to cut from stunt performer to
actor
number 16 head writer michael waldron
was brought on to take multiverse of
madness into a whole new direction as
the sets were being built he was given a
mere three weeks to write the picture
however the last week produced major
chaos for the production the pandemic
hit halting production for months this
didn't bring down the spirits of these
filmmakers however they decided to take
this time to rewrite it again michael
was actually relieved to have this
unexpected time with the script because
it seemed like he wasn't all too happy
with his draft anyways
number 17 a director's best actor is a
director's best friend so is the case of
bruce campbell and sam raimi tearing
through the industry together bruce has
been there for sam since the evil dead
rocked cinemas and even those classic
appearances in all three toby maguire's
spider-man films as for this appearance
it seems like he was a little shocked
sam was actually directing a real actor
for a change cough cough benedict
cumberbatch but that little snarky
comment sentenced him for the majority
of his scenes to get painfully entranced
by doctor strange don't beat yourself up
too much for that bruce we thought it
was pretty hilarious
number 18. who wants to be an mcu
superhero well you're just a couple
years too late when the nationwide
search for america chavez began casting
went far and wide to find the perfect
actress for the role social was one of
the many that auditioned in march of
2020 but didn't land the part so quickly
she had to wait a painstaking six months
before she got the screen test and the
rest is comic book history to have the
mcu creative team vote for you
unanimously surely means you were the
best fit for america
number 19 one of the godfathers of the
mcu sam raimi jumped at the opportunity
to direct the doctor strange sequel he
not only loved the character himself but
sam was more impressed with the
performance of benedict cumberbatch
raymie's reputation precedes himself
having taken on the first film
adaptation of spider-man putting him on
the superhero map everyone was all in
for bringing him into direct in fact a
lot of the main creative team wouldn't
have found their passions for filmmaking
without the inspiration from sam to get
to work with sam is a dream come true
not just for me but for most of the
people on this set and did you know
marvel executive producer kevin feige
worked on those films as a junior
creative member from fetching copies to
head honcho what a journey that is
number 20 sam needed something crazy for
the second act so why not bring in the
illuminati filmmakers chose these
characters to give the fans what they
wanted but not what they expected and
they took great care in the specific
looks of the members with captain carter
sporting a similar look to captain
america's age of ultron look and
professor xavier's classic suit from the
x-men series this scene was chock full
of the coolest marvel references and we
were so happy to see the fan favorite
john krasinski tackle the role of reed
richards there's certainly a lot of
madness that went into the massive set
pieces but good thing bruce campbell was
there to lighten the mood oh and the
tick tock dances those are the best way
to put a smile on benedict cumberbatch's
face so we know dr strange will return
what adventure do you think they'll
explore next let us know in the comments